when we talked about the case against
Donald Trump much of it is about Donald
Trump specifically and it's about Donald
Trump policy and Donald Trump
cluelessness and Donald Trump
incompetence and just lack of fitness
temper mentally unfit to be President of
the United States but a big part of the
danger of a Donald Trump presidency is
not only that it would make the United
States a laughingstock around the world
but it's a danger in terms of the people
and actions that it would embolden and
we have to look no further than a video
recorded by Memphis man Brandon leviston
who goes by Skylab on the internet he
was involved in a road rage incident
which resulted in him being on the
receiving end of a just violent racist
rant including the n-word and so many
other things like black lives don't
matter the man you're going to see in
this video that I'm going to play audio
and video from has been identified as
neil thompson and lev explained that
neil thompson wouldn't let him pass
while driving the man claims lev was
speeding around him and forced him to
slam on his brakes no surprise a road
rage incident where there are
drastically different stories about who
was doing what what we don't have
different stories about fortunately
because we have video is what happened
when the two men pulled over and left
oook out his phone to record the other
man coming up and approaching him you
are going to hear some pretty horrible
language in this video I'm gonna play
just a little bit of it for it for you
this video has been going viral it is
rancid it is disgusting it is a trump
supporter and this is exactly the type
of behavior that is emboldened by Donald
Trump let's take a look cuz black lives
don't matter
there ain't no proof just because you
say something don't mean nothing
[Music]
appreciate it no black legs don't mad no
the problem of traffic was you were
right behind me sped up and drove around
me jumped in front of me made me slam on
my brakes out of light that makes you a
[ __ ] man that proves dance check it
out that proves that black lives don't
matter hey no no not if you have a side
if you have a subject you tell me why
black lives matter because people say so
you tell me why how you know what matter
means is something makes a difference
and let me tell you something Martin
Luther King died for a purpose and you
know watch the very first episode of
boondocks
because he walks around ashamed of the
people with the flat bill hats like you
and the people that can't even keep
their pants up I put it on Facebook I
don't care if race I don't care look at
me you're a punk that lives off social
media I don't even have a social media
account you know why because white lives
matter dude it I appreciate you sharing
me your life story sir was there
anything of anybody's past are you just
another [ __ ] that doesn't understand
anything
black people were bought about a
contract and we got ripped off because
y'all shoulda got returned when it was
evidence and proof D I couldn't do
anything
so because y'all welfare drop like a
[ __ ] that's why so uncomfortable to
watch and hey did you notice him saying
to the woman in his car hey hey hey hey
hey let me handle this be a woman is
anybody shocked that the racist guy is
also a flaming misogynist I'm not I mean
I think it pretty much correlates
doesn't it right I mean it's very
disturbing to watch we should point out
that of course this is not even close to
the majority of Trump supporters sure
but the Republican Party has been
dealing with racism for a long time ever
since LBJ signed the South away in the
60s yep and it's a problem that persists
and we see it we see it in this and I'm
more worried by those
Boldin by a trump presidency then the
trump presidency itself as horrible as
that would be also later on in the video
we don't have time for the entire rant
but he also started referring to the
driver as a transgender [ __ ] so
transphobic and homophobic this is
basically deplorable Trump supporter
bingo and this guy is a parody of
himself it's almost like he's trying to
prove how insane he is and if Trump wins
these deplorable --zz will be coalesced
and catalyzed and emboldened even more
than they've been merely by Trump's
presidency and this garbage is going to
escalate for four years now one of
Thompson's neighbors said something like
oh he's a great neighbor and I like him
and you know he's not I don't know that
he's actually racist or basically just
defended all this well it's great that
at least his neighbor thinks that he's a
knight a nice guy right did this happen
Pat because of economic anxieties and
trade deals that Donald Trump is going
to fix I mean is that why this guy
supports Trump because this this tirade
was caused by NAFTA or something like
that or is this just one of those
deplorable --zz that we keep hearing
about no it comes from the rhetoric that
you hear at Trump rallies and there are
actual policies that Donald Trump would
put forward that would put this into act
I mean you can look at the Muslim man
that he proposes sure which is another
yeah maybe that's canceled or I guess
the wall but oh maybe maybe the walls
cancelled too who knows what the Trump
policies are I mean it's election day we
have no idea what Trump's actual
proposals are at this point other than
he'll put good people around himself
which we know he couldn't do during the
campaign and he will figure it out later
which we know that he hasn't been able
to do with his campaign either so this
ladies and gentlemen is what we're going
to have a lot of if Donald Trump wins
tonight let's take a break I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman next my prediction
for what will happen tonight in the
election today's program is made
possible in part by custom menswear line
endowed Chino I told you how I had
gotten my custom suit measured by Chris
at the Boston Indo Chino showroom I went
in last week to have the
almost finished product measured and
today I'm actually going in to pick up
the the tailored version some small
tweaks were made after the suit came in
and I love the experience Chris was
great to work with I would often buy off
the rack
suits and they really weren't that
inexpensive but they just didn't fit
right even when I had them tailored and
at Indo Chino they basically build a
suit for you from the ground up I know
nothing about how to build a suit from
the ground up so fortunately I had Chris
there to help and advise me in terms of
what it is that makes sense in terms of
pockets in terms of fabric in terms of
colors and buttons and all of that stuff
but even if you don't live near a
showroom you can submit your
measurements online if you go to Indo
Chino com they actually give you
instructions for how to measure what is
necessary to custom build a suit for you
and this week in particular it's a very
exciting week my listeners can get any
premium Indo Chino suit for just 389 at
Indo Chino comm but you must enter the
code Packman at checkout that's PA que
ma n to save 50% off the regular price
for a made-to-measure suit from Indo
Chino shipping is free satisfaction
guaranteed or your money back
that's promo code Pakman PA que ma n for
50% off